はいみなさんこんにちは外れ一つはです男子高校生何がスキーがご存知でしょうか
[音楽]
いっぱいですまあ男子高校生になればこ少なからずこうやっぱ女の子に興味を抱いてい
ます普通はね普通に2ようで言ってますよもうそれもう僕も例外ではなく
男子高校生にもなるとも女性の体ダストが気になりすぎててもう多分
胸が好きなんですよ8する女性の胸のふくらみなどにとても敏感になる時期でありまし
て今に原理ですね高校生のユーチューバーの弦にですか遊びに来ております
今ちょっと稼ぐで買い物に勝ってるんですけどねバカでもうなんやかんや1匹の男
そして男子高校生であるのでまぁ正常な男子高校生ならば目が大好きなはず
すなわち胸の膨らみには過剰な反応を酢水はずでございますってことは彼に僕が女性
じゃなくてもう僕の船が少しでもこう膨らんでいる少しでもコーチと
論に露わになってる感じであれば男性であっても胸のふくらみ興味を示すのではないか
急いで宮部られるのではないかということで男子高校生は本当に前が好きなのか一美波
のするのかということを検証していきたいとおもいます僕は純粋にですねここ順次に
男子高校生であるカレーの一人の男としての胸に対する熱い想い
熱意興味というものをどれだけのものなのかということちょっと実験で確かめてみたい
と思っておりますっていう気でね裏つけますこれすごいんですよつけると5倍盛り2名
が漏れるというやつですそもそも胸がないから
ん
うわぁあれこれてもさでこれはってでもさんこれなんかあれがないとだめじゃんこれ
だけだと多分ダメだよな
でもなんかで挑戦か
ああああそう言う音止めてスターヌーブラこれをこれヌーブラっていうんですけど胸に
付けると胸を守れるって奴なんですよその他からこの方もきっとすごいこうやって持っ
てるんですよねヌーブラって誰か普通に無難かと思ったら
つける部分がないぞ
これだなぁ
乳首が吸い取られるぞてこれすごいんじゃねーんだムーヴらの中ですよこれなんかこう
やってくっつくんですよだから直接胸に付けると作りが
あーやばい2てチクリとれるんじゃねこれあっあっああっ
[音楽]
おキタは来た来た来たはいうわああああああまずが普通に言えば胸にダイレクトつける
もんなのかわかりやすければいい
はぁはぁぁ
チャーム1みるるいるうわっ品を折れば俺はこれ俺か変わったああいいサイズか店げ
んっ
明け
も帰ってきたんですけど
[音楽]
ん
さあ良いはずありました胸を確認しつつターゲットが来るのまず
[音楽]
さあアパシーから帰ってきますターゲット
行ってきましたエロガッパつる兄です
c シールも忘れたようですね
さあどう出る胸にはまだ気づいていないか
[音楽]
オートいきなり大胆なアプローチで胸の存在に気付いているがすでに
だこれは無意識のようださあなにげない開業している中でターゲットは胸に気づくこと
ができるのか目線は金に向いているがまだ胸には気づいていないようですさあここで
どう仕掛けるか
夫胸を上げるまあこれは分かりやすい目線も行っているがわずかに逸れる
外れたまだ気付いていない
ん
そして固まる空気謎の注目何気ない時は2人は普段動画のネタの話をしていますがここ
からどうアプローチをかけるかここから見ても胸の膨らみはわかりやすいぞ
さあどうしていける
[音楽]
おっと胸を受けたん
お互いのため息をつく人生に疲れているのかさあ今だとどう仕掛けるか胸の膨らみは
ここからでも確認できますのであとはターゲットがどう反応できるかでございます
おああああなってしまったなぜ気付かないといった桜
これは分かりやすいぞ
わからないかまだ
いやーこれ分かるでしょさすがに
俺競ってわかるよ auto これセクシーポーズ
釣りにより船が向かった
バレたあああ
ああああああああ
おっぱおっ
おっぱいっ
me
me あった